salut cette année souvent qu'on a parlé
de mémoire on a parlé d' image en a
parlé de visualisation mais on a
rarement parler des sons et aujourd'hui
j'aimerais vous parler des sons même
d'un absolu dans les sons puisqu'on va
aussi parler de l'oreille absolue
je n'ai pas l'oreille absolue je ne sais
même pas si j'ai bonne définition de
l'oreille absolue et c'est pour ça que
j'ai invité robin qui lui là et on va
pouvoir en discuter ensemble
generix poste robin c'est le ironman de
la guitare et à la guitare d'iron man
mon pote merci romain d'être là c'est
cool mais merci à toi fabien le jeu qui
fleurit chant la guitare toi c'est
parfait est ce que tu peux nous donner
cette définition de l'oreille absolue
déjà tu vois alors déjà l'oreille
absolue il ya beaucoup d'idées reçues
là dessus c'est à dire que souvent s'est
présenté comme l'oreille ultime en fait
c'est l'oreille des génies l'art est un
génie musicor et alors que non pas du
tout l'oreille absolue ça peut aussi
simplement en
reconnaître une note dans l'absolu peu
importe ce que le son ils viennent d'un
instrument de musique ou pas en fait
c'est du temps en temps un son et est
capable de lire la note ça on est il ya
un petit soucis de caméra rien et on est
bon on est bon donc l'oreille absolue
l'oreille relative alors l'oreille
relatifs ça va être reconnaître une note
par rapport à une autre c'est à dire par
exemple
aussi si on croise ici
pour nous ici en fait
naître voilà que c'est un sol c'est une
canne juste si tu prends ici
superman à ces manoeuvres il avait aussi
est un
voilà c'est bon je leur ai absolue je me
casse et puis tu avoir l'oreille
harmonique aussi l'harmonie de l'oreille
harmonix esquiva permet de reconnaître
un accord
[Musique]
il combine voilà qui conduit plusieurs
notes et à ce moment là on va parler de
couleur d'accord alors je rebondis chers
amis sur votre mot couleurs parce qu'on
a une petite conversation intéressante
donc on a un café avec monsieur robin où
tu me dis tu m'as fait un parallèle à un
moment donné sur sur les couleurs
rapport aux notes je le consentis se
passe tu veux ça vient comme ça
viendrait voilà moi c'est ce que
montanes et or en fait et voilà et c'est
le roi du blues c'est là qu'est sonné à
la camp et on voit un bleu n'importe
quelle gamme du bleu d'ailleurs on dit
automatiquement c'est un bleu plus la
même manière tentant un son tu vas dire
automatiquement c'est elle notre cas et
de la même manière je me disais ça là
pendant que tu préparé la guitare tolar
et ben c'est vrai que je suis incapable
de décrire une couleur hier que va
expliquer par exemple quelqu'un qui a eu
comme qui est non voyant de naissance va
lui expliquer ce qui est du versé
impalpable c'est pas possible tu vois et
la même manière tu peux pas expliquer ce
qu'est un dolois là où on a mis une
heure et s'est fait trop compliqué c'est
un palpable il faut des seuils de
référence pour pouvoir expliquer par
rapport à quelque chose
donc ça veut dire qu'on est sensé tous
est capable de travailler ce phénomène
exactement l'oreille absolue entre
guillemets quoi exactement est sage de
voix quand je donne des cours à l'examen
final on voit l'épreuve le progrès petit
à petit on développe une certaine
oreille alors c'est vrai quoi
aujourd'hui on parle enfin comment dire
l'oreille absolue c'est pas une fin en
soi c'est à dire ça pas l'oreille
forcément musicale en fait la musique
c'est beaucoup des coudes beaucoup de
d'émotion on va dire oui de ressentir en
fait des choses c'est ça qui va faire ta
musicalité ça qui me force pas le fait
de savoir t notes je crois qu'on a un
problème nous culturel sur le son ou on
ne délaisse alors que s'ils ont
travaillé dès le départ juste notre
capacité à reconnaître c'est qu'on est
petit à la maternelle ont fait des jeux
genre homo je me souviens de ce jeu là
il y avait un bac jaune un pack rouge et
un pack bleu et on avait des objets
fallait qu on les range au bon endroit
donc un citron un tabac dans le bac
jaune parce que le citron et jaune et
c'est comme ça qu'on fait
l'apprentissage des couleurs si on
faisait la même chose avec avec les
notes de musique à la clé son sein
en habituerai directement le cerveau
avoir sombré seuil de référence à avoir
sa boucle ses boucles sonores qui tourne
quelque part dans dans la tête et qui
nous servirait après comparer on se
poserait pas la question
la même manière que le là on va le
définir la majeure la misr lel assez
fiable tout ce que tu veux
il ya le jaune pâle le jaune foncé le
jaune poussin le jaune tout ce que tu
veux
donc on serait capable aussi de trouver
un procès nuance meiway faudrait faire
un apprentissage complet dès le départ
moi j'ai expliqué à robin un truc je
m'appuie piètre jeu désolé cmh et nous
expliquer à robin un truc tout à l'heure
c'est que souvent je vous parle d'image
moi je vais au delà des images en fait
en général je fonctionne en trois
dimensions donc j'ai une situation chez
les images de cette situation j'ai
l'émotion j'ai le temps qui passe j'ai à
chaleur j'ai les odeurs j'ai les
sensations je crois que vous les 10 g
les sons qui arrive donc voilà je cumule
avec tout ça est en fait pour les sons
j'utilise des sons de ma mémoire de ma
vie tu vois le coucou qui avait chez mon
grand-père des trucs comme ça
mais si j'étais capable de maîtriser en
fait les notes comme je le souhaite je
suis sûr que je gagnerais encore plus
nommé technique domaine moralisation je
pense que nous partageons voiture toi tu
parles de ce genre de choses sur le site
où tu m'as parlé de ce genre de choses
alors oui je vais en parler juste avant
l'article
c'est bien comme ça on peut le lire à
tête reposée
n'oubliez pas description il ya le lien
vers le site d'europe donc c'est à dire
que six mois par exemple aveugle je te
fais la tournée se prend la guitare
alors là on n'est pas du tout dans
l'apprentissage là on est dans mon kiff
bon alors eu l'idée c'est ça je te fais
des notes et tu dises que cette coutume
vous m nous on te fais une confiance
absolue
attention c'est parti je commence gentil
entendus note à note
non
alors donc oui ou non ces troisièmes
cazaux l'accord oui c'est ça une fois
que je réfléchisse en vantant le timbre
en fait c'est moi quand je connais bien
la guitare je sais que j'ai l'impression
eyes et drôle alors dis moi où j'ai mon
doigt [ __ ] cette phrase est tellement
celle où les mais dites moi où j'ai mon
doit pas tomber tu n'as pas ton doigt
sur une guitare lattaf et demi à vide
c'est un piège et
bien sûr alors ça marche ce qu'il a dit
c'est comme si j'avais fait le mit à
vide puisque je suis sur le mythe de la
corde précédente
c'est la même chose en fait
j'aurais pas cru email ok mais mais
c'est bien joué puisque forcément c'est
exactement la même note
où est mon doigt si mes mains j'irai au
troisième case de la corde de sol
non pas du tout c'est un business j'ai
réfléchi vient parfaire la banda eu
alors ceux qui connaissent pas la
musique à la diète ainsi bill vol c'est
la même chose en fait est-ce que j'ai le
jeu tombe de trois accords et tu trouves
l'accord et ça marche donc là on est sur
l'oreille harmonique
on est plutôt sur l'harmonie frais
oreilles harmonie doivent haïr modique
ces partis hier
[Musique]
bien sûr les nageurs oui
oui en plus je joue pas toutes les
cordes
de bien jouer attention c'est parti
c'est les frères misère pour ceux qui
connaissent
le mano solo
amine six mois mais oui c'est énorme
attention nouvelles difficultés j'ai
trouvé une dernière idée pour leur
mettre une dernière fois au défi je
prends un son de n'importe où du fin
fond de ma tête je le siffler tu me dis
la note que c'est une fois que tu as dit
que c'est pour me prouver que c'est bon
tu t'es sûr ça marche il se sent guère
flatteur est plutôt fade yeahs et à ses
salariés absolument pas être plus aigus
rendrait un petit peu plus grande alors
ça c'est un rêve alors est ce que je
sais encore faire ça alors je mets donc
ces dominos à mi-mollet
[Musique]
ses amis
ça
tam est en fait chaud compositeur de
génie mais qu il fallait juste un mec
comme toi pour après exploiter mon génie
d'un producteur l'aï lâché direction
quel est le mois de la fin de tout ça à
robin le mot de la fin c'est que ça peut
se travailler en fait c'est que ça peut
se blesser bas c'est je pense que tout
un chacun peut développer l'aurait alors
forcément dans tous les domaines chacun
va avoir plus ou moins de prédisposition
par là c'est quand même partout elle
c'est un discours que je tiens pour la
mémoire sympa voilà ma typiquement
j'avais essayé ton tour de cartes savoir
reconnaître dans l'ordre les cartes
rouges et les avenirs les rouges et les
noirs
et ouais j'avais trouvé ça complètement
bluffant parce que au bout d'une heure
et demie j'ai failli
moi je suis tellement ravie quand je
sais qu'il y en a qui était et qui
s'auto bluff même à réussir
bon allez voir le site manière puisque
tu vas faire un nouveau billet là dessus
d'un nouvel artiste dans la description
toujours mais j'ai déjà dit tellement de
fois mon garçon et a aussi une chaîne
internet je vous invite à la découvrir
je vous mettrai ça peut-être pas des
affiches veut également dans la
description c'est plus simple tout est
au même endroit c'est mieux j'espère que
ça vous a plu
si c'est le cas comme d'hab vous pouvez
cliquer et vous abonner et rendez vous
demain à 17h ciao
[Musique]
il